hey guys it's justine and this video
today is something that i have been
waiting for i think my entire life if
you guys are fans of lego and nintendo
they have come together to basically to
make all of our childhood dreams come
true so i got a chance to do a zoom call
with jonathan from lego and he had one
of the starter kits and the piranha
expansion kit on his desk and it's so
cool i was so jealous there's also one
more expansion set it's the bowser
castle set and this thing looks so great
i was trying to contain my excitement
during the zoom call
bowser's castle looks incredible i know
it may not have seemed like i was that
excited but i knew that i was recording
and if i talked then my little voice
bubble would pop over top of what he was
showing me but it's so awesome so the
pre-orders are starting very soon if not
already depending upon when you watch
this the starter set will be out august
1st and this is the starter kit which
comes with the little digital mario
figure the other sets don't come with
mario so you definitely need to have the
starter kit so that the expansion sets
will work with the starter kit but the
digital mario there's actually a lot of
tech built into this little guy so it
has an accelerometer a gyroscope it has
a little sensor in the bottom which is
actually a little camera he also has a
built-in led on the front speakers and
bluetooth so with his little camera
sensor it determines what color bricks
he's on and that's how you get coins he
also will read different barcodes so
there's barcodes that are placed on
various obstacles like goomba or the
coin blocks so you can see here in this
little video demo that when he hits the
blue bricks his front little digital
display reads as water and then when you
put him on the red bricks yep you
guessed it it's lava you love 60 seconds
to complete all of these courses to
gather as many coins as possible and you
don't lose lives in this little lego
game you'll lose time so if you hit the
water or the lava for example mario will
just kind of pause so you're not able to
collect coins during that time if you
want to use other lego bricks to kind of
build out these sets this is super
exciting because you can also do that as
i'm sure many of us have extra bricks
laying around the color sensor though
only works with kind of the primary lego
colors so any of the green red blue or
yellow bricks that you have his color
sensor will work with those and you can
still collect coins this is really
awesome oh my gosh so like how long has
this been in development is the real
question i've been over four years um
but we felt that when lego and nintendo
would do something together we needed to
make it count and we wanted to make it
special and also you know reinvent how
kids play with with lego bricks and how
kids play with mario and you know that
takes a little bit of time mario has a
built-in speaker so you can hear the
interactions and collecting coins
and then you get five coins as well
different enemies give different coins
the uh the cloud platform
which is a personal favorite and the
accelerometer and gyroscope is kind of
interesting so using this little
obstacle this is a little cloud you can
transport mario from one set to another
so if you want to split up your sets in
the room you can take mario on his
little cloud and be collecting coins all
the way to the other set put that in the
starter set because we want kids to kind
of use their whole room as levels so now
they can just build the start maybe on
one side of the room and then the finish
on the other and then with the cloud
you fly
between
that's cool most of these functions have
like little secrets in them jonathan did
say there's some secrets to collecting
coins but he wouldn't tell me what they
were to uh so the cloud actually has a
secret to get a lot of coins from it if
you know exactly what to do so i guess
we're just going to figure that out for
ourselves mario does have bluetooth
built in and there is a companion app so
you can connect the app to mario you'll
be able to update him and when you get
expansion sets you'll be able to let him
know that hey guess what mario hi we've
got some expansion sets so you're able
to update him that way and in the app it
also has instructions and different
types of videos to help inspire your set
building but they don't have set
instructions on how to build the sets
mary has a bluetooth
button
and it allows you to connect to a uh
like a campaign app on the mobile phone
or tablet and once you're all set up you
don't actually need the app to play
because everything runs on lego mario i
was surprised at the price because
obviously lego sets are more on the
expensive side especially for something
so advanced like this the starter set
including the digital mario is 59.99 the
piranha expansion kit is 29.99 and that
massive bowser one is 99.99 i'd love to
hear from you guys though what do you
think about this are you excited is this
something that you've been waiting your
whole life for as well because i know i
definitely have hopefully i can get one
here soon to show you guys all how it
works but until then i'm just gonna be
sitting over here staying at home and
playing animal crossing because i mean
what else
do we have to do